but of course the next category a
favorite of ours the best nickname do we
have any news this year I feel like I
feel like we didn't but some of our
guests did uh and uh we had some pretty
funny ones as well uh and stuff that
happened off camera as well uh so these
nominations are bulge Lee
so actually I I joined the stream I
joined your stream like two days in how
did this start do you want to explain
how we were doing kawara tile smashing
which is you know you just smash it as
you see you've seen it in the movies and
stuff whatever yeah and show you oh my
God he's so strong he can hit an animate
object hard
um and so I put on an outfit and I guess
my junk was just like enunciated quite
heavily in this junk and it was all chat
could talk about the whole time I was
doing it and it was the it was a Bruce
Lee outfit so they named me boldly and
they're just kind of stuck I guess
people loved it and that is just
laughing his ass off the whole time
saying every time I walked out he's like
I feel like what made this nickname
stick was the fact that he just ended up
breaking the record you
said I couldn't believe during that
moment definitely having practice with
the time we did it I think helped a lot
yeah sure I knew the technique going in
last year we had affable Chris this year
we had haughty Connor yeah uh which is
uh I don't know like I honestly I'd
never heard of this word before you told
me I'd never heard of this word either
and I was like I cannot find a word that
more accurately represents you yeah
that is now permanently ingrained you
can look in the depths of the thesaurus
and there'll be nothing more that
explains it yeah we've got to go through
like all of us now there must be like a
new word to describe all of us every
year so I think so yes and then we also
have uh the greatest uh prank that was
ever pulled Barry Johnson
I was [__] dying in the taxi when you
pulled when you fell for that [__]
this is like Ain't No Way
Dusty was skipping the band Chopsticks I
don't remember this one I don't remember
die Dorsey but it makes sense
yeah I don't remember when this was
mentioned but this was mentioned a few
times on the nominations
and I'm like it checks out it checks out
sounds like something I would have said
all right all right so we have four
nominations let's see who's taking it
home come on have your votes placed all
right the winner is
Barry chopsticks
I'm surprised this not this didn't get
nominated for best story as well
such a good story I got unrightfully
trolled no reason what's the breakdown
very Chopsticks
48.4 oh God what was second yeah
that makes sense that makes sense
moving on to the next one which is best
meme that is awesome uh so as you know
we all we always get some very very good
memes on the Reddit and a lot of Twitter
posts yeah uh so we wanted to
congratulate some people who actually
you know went out of the way and made
great memes out of the episodes and
moments that have happened during the
previous year all right let's check it
out the best memes are Connor streamer
Awards the corner streamer award memes
there were a bunch of these on the on
his uh I'm sorry like there's one I
really liked is when I walk up yeah
people memed the walk up a bunch and it
was like you know me when I get a triple
kill on fortnite standing up going like
I think I think the reason there's not
one meme of this because this spawned so
many memes in the subreddit but it was
just your pure reaction of just shock
and surprise yeah I didn't expect to win
yeah I was like what the [__]
um where ribs Corner was also a big
thing as well that took over the subway
like I got like 90 000 likes when I
tweeted their picture out Jesus Christ
some people again because it matches so
perfectly with the skin so some people
always thought it was real on the first
glance it's real and then you look at it
for a second you're like oh okay but
like for the first glance you're like oh
God whoa you can see where it ends yeah
yeah yeah I'll be honest when I first
saw this pop up into the subreddit
because I didn't get to watch this
stream live I was like oh my God what
the [__] has happened to Connor got
[__] damn I wish I drink far too much
beer
we've also got a Dr ligma baby man
the aftermath of the uh the dark
timeline memes that spawns last year
last year I did win last year uh we got
all of the wedding memes as well yeah my
favorite uh of the wedding memes is the
uh Ava parody we did
oh yeah
everyone all the boys just like
you congratulations I gotta thank you
for that Joey because I I always
remember that moment where all the boys
were together for a photo and Joey was
like this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity we should do the Ava
congratulations right now and I was like
oh my God Joey you are right you are
right it turned out so well yes and it
was it was literally a once in a
lifetime opportunity so thank you very
much my boy reminded me of that uh when
Conor has an opinion
my my favorite one of when Connor has an
opinion is when uh I think it was a year
or two ago of the slow motion footage of
me and uh just like looking towards the
camera there's so many variations
uh we got how these two look at each
other whenever they be I can't remember
who is she
the holy [__] that's such a good answer
such a good edit
that's so good holy [__] oh we got uh
the level of disappointment in Pro zd's
eyes yeah that's uh that's pretty much
how that episode went yeah
I don't even know about this
yeah this service
it was yeah it's got 11 000 yeah
yeah
oh God I [__] hate Twitter
yeah I just found out I got raped 11
000 likes of Joey getting ratio uh Gone
0.1 seconds after getting married to an
American
we've got the 30-foot cartels
yeah oh the dark timeline trip okay this
one I remember this is good it was good
yeah should we should we watch this one
this one deserves
[Music]
hahaha
I [__] the one with Corner screaming
is my favorite show I think
this is
way too well edited oh my God there's so
much [__] this is so good
bro holy fog
it's your boy Chris very nice very good
meme there's also the trash days anime
intro yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
that's so good
[Music]
[Applause]
what the [__] holy [__] oh none of us
seen this
oh my God
[Music]
what the [__]
oh my God
you guys have way too much this is
incredible
holy [__]
[Music]
this is uh what we should have used this
as the intro for the trash case Awards
this year yeah right this literally
it's crazy yeah
what the actual [__]
[Music]
went hard
whoever made that that's insane dude
what the hell I want that annoying after
seeing all that yeah I was gonna say uh
I think what I like about the trash days
after dark was it was such a good meme
that it kind of like I I see that as the
end of the after dark meme kind of like
timeline yeah I think everything kind of
like tapered off after this meme was
posted I think so anime intro I don't
know I do not know how I missed this one
because that
what is it
so tell us there were a lot of
nominations this year so many so many
good memes and uh so many good memes we
just watched right now fresh but the
best meme of the trash taste Awards this
year goes to
the dark timeline trailer
honestly I am I'm surprised it won yeah
yeah I thought people wouldn't have the
patience to sit there one minute 30
videos
okay okay
followed by when Connor has an opinion
[__]